اجراءات عده اتخذتها وزاره الخزانه
الامريكيه بالتشاوري مع الرئيس جو بايدن
ومع البنك الاحتياطي الفيدرالي لتجنب
تداعيات انهيار بنك سيليكون فالي ولتمكين
المودعين من الحصول على اموالهم ان الله
اكرر لا خسائر سيتحملها دافع والضرائب من
اهم ما اكد عليه الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
خلال كلمته هو ان جميع اموال المودعين
ودافع مؤمنه ويمكن الحصول عليها من دون
عائق وطلب من الامريكيين الثقه في النظام
المصرفي فقبل هذه الازمه كانت الحكومه
الفيدراليه تضمن من خلال المؤسسه
الفيدراليه للتامين على الودائع الودائع
التي لا تزيد قيمتها عن 250 الف دولار
قاعده 250 الف دولار ستستمر ولن تتراجع
الحكومه عنها السبب الوحيد لتعليقها
للبنكين منع العدو الماليه لكن الحكومه
ستغير بعض اللوائح في المستقبل لمحاوله
الحد من اي خطر معنوي ربما يكون قد تسببوا
فيه عبر اقتراح ان الحكومه ستتدخل دائما
لانقاذ المودعين لكن الوضع بالنسبه
للمستثمرين الذين يخاطرون بودائع
الامريكيين مختلف وفق بايدن لانهم لن
يحظوا باي حمايه فيما تعهد بمحاسبه
المسؤولين عن ازمه البنوك معتبرا ان لا
احد فوق القانون
سيتم طرد اداره هذه البنوك اذا تم
الاستيلاء على البنك من قبل المؤسسه
الفيدراليه للتامين على الودائع فيجب على
الاشخاص الذين يديرون البنك الا يعملوا
هناك بعد الان
بايدن وعد بان الاجراءات لحمايه المودعين
ولعدم تكرار اخفاقات البنوك ستستمر الى ان
تنتهي ازمه مصرفي سيليكون فالي وسجنتشر
فيما سيطلب من الكونجرس تجديد القوانين
المتعلقه بالبنوك حسين الطاوض العربيه
واشنطن